they two of rapid as a 20-17  Grantchester in levin belgian it was  another day full of excitement at the  best players in the world look to rack  up the points against the competition  world champion magnus carlsen bounce  back from yesterday's loss with two  dominant wings to finish the day tied  for second i was good to get a win now  and also one that was you know had  composed it to say so I'm optimistic  about day one leader Wesley so lack of  two victories of the gold as we finished  one spirit year is larger it's all about  form and getting that great form is the  real mystery here if the last chance is  for zinc in the basses they free  actually coming up